attention nous voici à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de lyon au club de la
reynière où la plupart des naturistes
lyonnais retrouvent leurs éléments
apparemment un camp qui ressemble
davantage à un petit village chacun il
dispose de 100 mètres carrés qui
l'agrémentent selon son goût 70
bungalows une quarantaine de caravanes
et un nombre égal de tentes le tout
réparti sur 10 hectares voilà de quoi
satisfaire aux goûts des 500 adhérents
lyonnais et de leurs deux cents enfants
de nombreux helvétiques ont également
choisi le camp de villette d'anthon en
guise de résidences secondaires
séduit par sa propreté son élégance et
ses installations
car outre ses parkings extérieurs son
restaurant etc sanitaire parfaitement
équipé le camp de villette d'anthon
propose aux naturistes deux terrains de
volley plusieurs tables de ping-pong une
aire de jeux pour enfants un emplacement
réservé au badminton et à la pétanque et
une indispensable piscine où les enfants
disposent de leur propre bassin
peut-être de quoi séduire les plus
réticents ils sont déjà vingt mille en
france en progression constante les cent
mille adhérents seront sans doute
atteint avant dix ans
mais qu'elles sont croyez vous les
raisons qui font choisir le naturisme
c'est la question que nous avons posée à
monsieur prix m'a délégué régional de la
ffn mais nous estimons que dans le monde
surmené actuelle le besoin de loisirs de
repos et de grand air va est déjà devenu
important et va devenir de plus en plus
important or une masse très valable de
familles recherchent ces loisirs est ce
grand air d'une dans la simplicité et
dans la ration complète morale et
physique de la famille
par conséquent ils seront attirés par
notre mouvement
tout cela en raison de son caractère
encore méconnue la été rendue possible
que grâce à des capitaux privés par la
volonté de naturistes convaincu enclos
dans ses limites le club a déjà cessé
d'intriguer les ignorants en de
nombreuses occasions les portes du camp
s'ouvre sur le public intéressé ce soit
par exemple c'est la fête annuelle du
club
initié et néophytes s'y retrouveront un
long chemin déjà a été parcouru la
population de villette nous a adoptés
depuis déjà fort longtemps puisque la
section a été créée en 1950
donc les gens du village nous
connaissent et chaque occasion que nous
avons nous les invitons à nos
manifestations
ils viennent tout terrain les
commerçants viennent servir les gens du
du club
et chaque fois qu'ils viennent ils sont
reçus aimablement et les gens ne
prennent ne s'habille pas pour faire
leurs provisions auprès des commerçants
donc ils savent ce qu'il se passe
ils nous connaissent par nos noms et je
pense que la population nous adopter
plus déjà longtemps